ketzer sind ein faszinierender
bestandteil der kirchengeschichte damit
verbundenen erschütternde tragödien
verbrannten die einen auf dem
scheiterhaufen wurden andere gnadenlos
in die verbannung geschickt der
berühmteste fall von ketzerei ist wohl
der fall galileo galilei der historische
sündenfall der katholischen kirche
gegenüber der wissenschaft der streit
mit galilei markiert zudem die trennung
zwischen wissenschaft und kirche in
einer halben stunde zeigen wir ihnen
dazu den film die akte galilei erst aber
fragen wir nach was denn sein ketzer
ausmacht denn die frage stellt sich
schon warum die kirche auf
nonkonformisten provokateure und
querdenker immer gleich so heftig
reagiert
hans schulz hat den luzerner
kirchenhistoriker markus rieß eingeladen
markus rieß haben sie als
kirchenhistoriker so etwas wie ein
lieblings ketzer ein mit dem sich am
intensivsten beschäftigt haben ja es
gibt natürlich verschiedene
persönlichkeiten die sehr beeindruckend
sind lieblingsgericht vielleicht ein
bisschen schwierig aber sozusagen in
didaktischer sicht ist es sicher
giordano bruno der eben wegen seiner
überzeugung wegen eines abweichenden
glaubens bestraft und dann hingerichtet
worden ist
aber leute wie bruno bleiben wir noch
mal bei dem doch lieblings ketzer für
den kirchenhistoriker ist es doch
spannend dass es diese cats war gab die
sind doch so was wie dass das salz das
was sie auch in ihrer arbeit haben sonst
wäre es vielleicht viel langweiliger
gekommen ja also es geht ja nicht nur
einfach um spannung und abwechslung aber
nur ist es eben schön dass er eine folge
geschichte hat der wird zu beginn der
frühen neuzeit hingerichtet aber er wird
dann später richtig verehrt man baut im
in rom 1 1 bronze denkmal und noch heute
können sie an diesem denkmal also
zeichen der verehrung es gibt da noch
gedenkfeier also er steht immer noch für
eine bestimmte haltung und das macht ihn
eben wie gesagt in gewisser weise
didaktisch interessanten unterstellten
schön blumenmarkt das ist ja noch mal
eine besondere ehre
damals war ja wenn wir das mal zeitlich
einordnen also erst im februar 1610
gerichtet worden
damals galt es zu einem ein verstopfter
bösewicht warum warum hat die kirche in
unbedingt beseitigen wollen ja weil man
in dem was wofür er stand eben einen
gefährlichen irrglauben sah der auch
praktisch stand die gesellschaft zu
offizieren droht also man könnte es fast
ein bisschen so vergleichen wie umgang
mit bse nicht man muss die
krankheitserreger eingrenzen und man
muss sie das macht man ja auch mit mit
mit tieren die bse haben nicht die
verbrennt man ja und zwar nicht nur um
sie zu bestrafen in diesem falle sondern
bei den pats und war das auch so um die
gesellschaft vor ihnen und dem schaden
den sie verbreiten zu schützen oder das
gedankengut musste auch mit verbrannt
werden so wie man ja oft auch bücher
verbrannt wird ja die bücherverbrennung
und die verbrennung von cats und das
liegt sehr nahe beieinander
man hat in der frühen neuzeit angefangen
mit martin luther ja zum beispiel auch
die idee gehabt dass man den autor den
schädlichen autor gemeinsam mit seinem
werk verbrennen müsse und wenn er nicht
präsent war kam es vor dass man ihn auf
ein bild gemalt hat und dann eine
verbrennung in f&e also eine verbrennung
im bild durchgeführt hat das hat man mit
luther in worms gemacht und das hat man
auch mit zwingli in luzern gemacht über
also zwingendes bücher wurden auch
verbrannt lassen sie uns später
vielleicht noch mal kurz auf giordano
bono zurückkommen harrys der kalten und
nicht nur der katholischen kirche als
ketzer sondern auch bei den calvinisten
aber vielleicht sollten wir erstmal den
umstrittenen begriff des catchers klären
das ist ja in der geschichte mal
einstand titel gewesen
mal war es ein ehrentitel was ist es
denn für sie als kirchenhistoriker für
mich ist es zunächst einmal ein kirchen
geschichtliches phänomen das es mir
erlaubt den glauben der leute das
verhalten der leute zu einer bestimmten
zeit zu verstehen und den glauben selber
entsprechend zu beschreiben und gerade
beim catcher ist es ja so dass er
gemacht wird vor dem hintergrund seiner
zeit also ein ketzer einer weiche ein
nonkonformist ist etwas ganz anderes
je nachdem wie die situation wieder
kontext ist was an pluralismus bejaht
oder verneint wird was an pluralismus
als gefährlich betrachtet wird oder als
chance betrachtet wird das heute
übrigens noch so wir sagen ja auch heute
oft der benimmt sich wie ein ketzer oder
das war eine ketzerei oder so also es
ist auch in ein weltlicher begriff
gebrauchen mittlerweile ja gut es ist
natürlich so dass dich und es gibt
interessante migration von begriffen aus
dem aus dem religiösen bereich
die dann abgemildert in der zivilen welt
weiterleben zum beispiel der
steuersünder oder die steuer sollen drin
sind so ein beispiel ein sünder ist ist
ein schlimmer verbrecher ursprünglich
und dann wird es so auf eine ganz andere
weise gehoben und so ist es mit dem
ketscher auch rügen kommen wir noch
einmal auf die ketzer der damaligen zeit
zurück zum beispiel bruno schon gehört
was es ausgelöst hat in der kirche warum
haben ketzer so viel aggression
ausgelöst ich führe ich darauf zurück
dass man eben die soziale ordnung die
öffentliche ordnung in gefahr sah man
muss sich schützen vor der gefahr die
diese person verbreitet man sieht sich
selber natürlich auch in frage gestellt
man darf nicht vergessen es gibt ja die
wand aus zum beispiel kirchlicher sicht
oder auch aus gesellschaftlicher sicht
zu allen zeiten aber die einschätzung
des gefahrenpotentials das damit
verbunden ist ist eben je nach zeit ganz
unterschiedlich gibt es so etwas was
allen ketzern gemein war also ein
gemeinsamen länder quasi ja und das ist
ja auch das was sozusagen die heutige
rezeption ein stück weit noch bestimmt
oder auch die verehrung in
anführungsstrichen nämlich dass der
ketzer sich eben gegen eine autorität
auflehnt und das erzeugt er sympathie im
grunde bei mir auch nicht dass es eine
das ist eine autorität gibt die
herrschaft ausübt die das individuum
knechtet gerade in der neuzeit und dass
jemand dagegen auf steht
sie dürfen nicht vergessen großer
erneuerungs bewegungen
etwa die überwindung der sklaverei in
den vereinigten staaten haben genau so
begonnen dass einige die zunächst
durchaus als wir köpfe jahren geschaut
wurden sich gegen ein unrecht in dem
falle gestellt haben
gegen den mainstream der gesellschaft
gestellt haben und dass wir heute
dankbar sind für das was sie gemacht
also wenn man so will waren sie ihrer
zeit immer ein bisschen voraus
also die kids run die wir unseren es
gibt natürlich auch die anderen
verdienen wir vielleicht froh sind dass
ich dann ihre position nicht
durchgesetzt hat und die entsprechenden
halt vergessen worden sind
die geschichte ist natürlich immer in
gefahr eine geschichte der sieger zu
sein
also wir wissen sie auch vor allem von
galileo galilei wie sehr er derzeit
damals voraus war und wir wissen auch
wie übel man das damals genommen hat und
wie lange es gedauert hat galilei
wirklich dann auch in zu rehabilitieren
das war erst 1992 das ja eigentlich
erstaunlich am fall galilei wir werden
ja nur ein film über ihn sehen also noch
mehr über ihn hören pkw ist ganz
erstaunlich 400 jahre dauert so etwas
bis man sich dann mal entschuldigen kann
oder was zurücknehmen kann ja das sehen
sie ja auch wie sehr also diese eben
herrschafts mechanismen
institutionalisierte macht eben
funktioniert es gibt eine staatsraison
es gibt eine gesellschafts saison
es gibt eine kirchenreform das kann
natürlich so etwas nicht beschönigen
oder entschuldigen das ist ganz klar
aber es ist in der tat verblüffen und so
gesehen ist es ja bei galilei ganz genau
gleich das eben die nachgeschichte nicht
dass sich leute wie bertolt brecht zum
beispiel mit galileo auseinandersetzung
zwar in einer sehr eindrückliche weise
das ist ja hier mindestens so
bemerkenswert wie das faktum selber und
der gegenstand der gegenstand zeit um
dem ist damals gegangen ist
ketzer sind dort wo es dogmen gibt sie
kämpfen gegen dogmen an und klar in der
katholischen kirche gibt es nun mal
besonders viele dogmen deswegen war sie
wohl auch für ketzer besonders anfällig
ja gewiss doch also das sind die dogmen
halt fassbare
weltanschauungsgemeinschaft oder jede
überzeugungs gemeinschaft
eine politische partei muss sich ja
irgend in einem bestimmten zeitpunkt
einmal abgrenzen was ich würde gern ein
wenig erweitern nicht nur dort wo es
themen gibt sondern auch dort wo es
konventionen gibt neben einschränken
sind auch dort ist sozusagen dieser
mechanismus ketzerei eingrenzung
ausgrenzung zu beobachten
vor der hinrichtung ist journalist
giordano gruner jahr durch halb europa
geflohen damals und er ist eben auch sie
haben schon erwähnt in genf mal gelandet
bei den calvinisten dachte er könnte vor
der katholischen kirche fliehende dem
übertritt dann zu der kirche aber auch
dort kann schon ganz schnell wieder zu
zerwürfnissen also ist doch ein ketzer
wie bono hat es eigentlich mit jeder mit
jeder macht aufgenommen wenn man so will
ja das ist die eindrückliche
besonderheit in kirchen geschichtlicher
hinsicht bei bruno das retten im moment
wo es diese trennung gibt diese
konfessionelle trennung der konfessionen
sierung das leben auf beiden seiten
gleichermaßen anstößt es gibt noch
einige andere bei denen das der fall war
allerdings ist es praktisch fast eine
signatur des seit der renaissance des
non konformisten dass er eben und
beheimatet ist und ständig in bewegung
also mir fällt da als analoges beispiel
parat zu sein er ja irgendwie auch nie
länger das soll ist zwar 100 jahre
früher
aber da ist nie länger als irgendwie
drei jahre an einem bestimmten ort
gewesen und immer mit den autoritäten
angestoßen in basel mit der universität
in salzburg ist er angestoßen in st
gallen ist er mit dem mit der
stadtbehörde mit fabian zu weiteren
gestoßen also hier sehe ich durchaus
eine signatur des dessen konformen
konform oder kann man noch weitergehend
sind es auch querulanten oder sagen
zumindest provokateur gewesen ja gut die
übergange sind natürlich fließen je
nachdem wo jemand selber steht ist es
eine erfrischende innovation oder es ist
es ist ein lästiger quer
natürlich dieses provozieren wollen ist
das ein merkmal für cats oder müssen sie
einfach und es steckt so in ihnen drin
oder wollten sie auch wirklich
produziert es wird vielleicht zu merkmal
durch den faktischen gang der geschichte
weil nur so verschaffen sie sich gehör
nur so können sie in die annalen der
geschichte überhaupt eingehen
jene cassidy eben das im stillen
kämmerlein praktizieren die vielleicht
noch die wesentlich besseren ideen
hätten oder die wesentlich innovativen
ideen hatten sie werden natürlich nicht
bekannt wenn sie sich nicht auf den
tisch stellen
geschichtlich gesehen warum wurde dann
der eine hingerichtet der andere nicht
also galileo galilei wurde ein
fachverband aber giordano bruno wurde
verbrannt was war jetzt der unterschied
für die inquisition behörde ja gut 3
foto greven die kennt es natürlich davon
ab ob man zum zum widerruf bereit ist in
einem solchen system und galileo hat
galileo galilei hatte sehr
vordergründiger gemacht oder sacrificium
intellektuell oder roboter ob es nur zum
schein dass ich da dann die historiker
diskussion historikerinnen diskussion
aber in tat und wahrheit hängt ist
natürlich sehr stark von den umständen
ab von konstellationen von von
verbindungen auch es ist ja nicht ein
rechtssystem wie das unsere das eben
rechtssicherheit gewährt das eben dem
schlimmsten verbrecher auch ein minimum
an rechten zugesteht
das ist eine erst nach der aufklärung
der fall
wir haben es bei galileo beim showdown
bruno sowieso bei den mittelalterlichen
ketzern mit vormoderne justiz zu tun die
diese partei rechte wie wir sie heute
als selbstverständlich und segensreicher
fahren eben noch nicht gekannt haben
aber die anhörung vor der behörde die
heute glaubenskongregation heißt die
haben sich ja doch ziemlich lange
gehalten also auch die
befreiungstheologen aus südamerika
mussten danach an trends ja also hier
das ist eigentlich fast das ist ein fast
eine kirche geschichtliche tragik dass
eben das gerichtsverfahren im späten
mittelalter lich eigentlich was in der
kirche praktiziert wurde der eigenen
zeit voraus gewesen ist und beispielhaft
gewesen ist
auch in anderen bereichen der
kirchlichen verwaltung das dann aber
sozusagen die säkulare umwelt das
kirchliche niveau überholt hat und wir
im grunde genommen bis heute bei den
kirchlichen rechtsverfahren noch immer
nicht auf den verstand der
verfahrensgarantien sind wie sie in
ziviler gesellschaft heute in vielen
zivilen gesellschaft zeit verständlich
geberit noch mal zurück in die zeit was
die interessantesten ketzer gab also 16
ausgang des sechzehnten jahrhundert
beginn des 17
jahrhundert eine zeit in der ja auch
martin luther eigentlich noch relativ
streng war also für ihn war gab es
ketzer es gab feinde der öffentlichen
ordnung wie er das sagte er war ein
befürworter der verfolgung der
täuferbewegung also auch luther einen
eigentlich ein strenger herr der dann
später ja selber er zum ketzer wurde ja
hier spielt genau dieser punkt eine
rolle den ich eben auch angesprochen
habe dass der kontext von bedeutung ist
es hängt auch damit zusammen ob eine
einzige wahrheit die durchgesetzt werden
muss zum gunsten des ganzen
ob das ein plausible denkfigur sei oder
nicht und luther war sie zweifellos
plausibel
es ist also anders als man es vielleicht
in einer pluralen gesellschaft wider
unseren heute erfährt wo die autorität
prinzipiell immer in frage steht ist es
in der vormodernen zeit eben durchaus so
dass diese dieser anspruch der wahrheit
verpflichtet zu sein
durchaus offen kunden plausibel gewesen
ist nicht nur die kirchliche hierarchie
jetzt im katholizismus hat das für
richtig gehalten sondern es war auch den
leuten weithin plausibel auch den
zivilen autoritäten war das plausibel
dass es eine wahrheit gibt und dass sie
zum schutz der gesellschaft auch
verteidigt werden muss kann man bei
luther sagen es vom ketzer zum kirchen
vater geworden ja gut natürlich für die
kirchen der reformatorischen tradition
hat er natürlich eine unmittelbare
bedeutung und wird entsprechend auch
gesehen als derjenige der hier die bibel
in einer neuen weise gelebt hat und dem
es gelungen ist den anstoß zu geben das
christentum wieder zur ursprünglichen
form zurückzuführen reformer reformation
so zur ursprünglichen form
zurückzuführen mittlerweile ist es ja
ist die geschichte weiter gegangen auch
im bereich der anderen kirchen also der
katholischen kirche auch wird eben der
beitrag zur theologie der von blut
bekommt geschätzt und und da noch kam
der ist teil des kurses
was auffällt gut kirchengeschichte war
immer männer geschichte haben sie
erfahrung gibt es eine tänzerin
eigentlich auch in der geschichte ja
also kirchengeschichte war
wahrscheinlich nicht immer meiner
geschichte sondern sie ist als männer
geschichte verstanden und erzählt vogel
aber es gibt auch die geschichte der
frauen in der kirche die sich natürlich
aufgrund der überlieferung und
herrschafts bedingungen in anderer weise
dann ist sie weitergegeben worden ja ich
meine sonntag ist die berühmteste war
auf dem scheiterhaufen alsfeld gläubige
und auch als hexe natürlich war übrigens
natürlich auch die ganz frühen christen
also die geschichte des christentums ist
ja eigentlich auch eine eine ketzerei
gewesen oder die christen der früchte
der frühzeit waren unruhestifter ja da
haben sie durch einen ganz wichtigen
punkt angesprochen wenn wir uns darüber
gedanken machen wie entsteht
theologische reflexion
wodurch wird sie angetrieben im ersten
zweiten dritten jahrhundert der
geschichte des christentums dann heißt
eigentliche standard schulbuch antwort
es ist die pluralisierung und es sind
die später als abweichend ausgegrenzten
die eben überhaupt erst weit in die
theologische reflexion in gang gebracht
haben
war denn für sie jesus ein ketzer ja in
gewisser weise ist er auch nicht konform
gewesen jesus als jude innerhalb einer
bestimmten situation des judentums hat
er sich ja nicht einfach so
eingegliedert allerdings hätte
wahrscheinlich seine umgebung und er
selber es so verstanden wenn ich das
richtig sehe das eben jesus die das
judentum lebt und es in einer anderen
weise versteht und in einer anderen
weise interpretiert und für sich
verwirklicht als es der damaligen
tradition entsprochen hat aber ketzerei
im eigentlichen sinne wo man also
glaubenswahrheiten in abrede gestellt
oder wie die einen dann sagen leugnen
das könnte man hier sicher nicht so an
aber er hat so geändert ich meine steuer
faktisch auch die todesstrafe gegen
einen gottes lässt ja also im grunde
genommen ist die gotteslästerung ja so
jedenfalls ist es dann entsprechend
überliefert worden
sie müssen nicht vergessen es brauchte
auch eine plausibilisierung innerhalb
dieser überlieferung ist dieser kette
vorwurf natürlich ein wesentliches
moment jesus mit seinen revolutionären
ideen war wahrscheinlich sehr schwierig
für seine mitmenschen damals auch schon
ist auch dass ein merkmal von in
anführung klettert um jetzt in anführung
bei jesus gesagt dass man es den leuten
einfach nicht leicht macht dass man für
die umwelt schon fast unerträglich wird
ja das hat sich das hat aber bei jeder
gesellschaftlichen veränderung spielt
das natürlich eine rolle
ja aber natürlich also zentral für das
judentum auch schon damals ist ja die
frage wie wir das gesetz gelebt wenn man
verwendet ja große anstrengungen darauf
zu verstehen wie das gesetz dass gott
gegeben hat gemeint ist wer sich in
diesem oder jenem fall verhält und dann
kommt jemand und stellt hier ganz andere
anforderungen an die umsetzung
verwirklichung dieses auftrages
das ist natürlich im gewissen sinne auch
beunruhigend kann man ja
in dem maß in dem sich dann die kirche
die sich auf jesus beruft zu einer
öffentlichen größe dann auch hinterher
entwickelt hat begann sie dann selber
die unruhestifter auszuschließen
provoziert nicht eigentlich jede große
organisation sie haben vorhin schon auch
mit staaten verglichen und so die für
sich die absolute wahrheit eigentlich
programmiert provoziert das nicht
automatisch ketzerei ja gut dass er so
lange die wahrheit als einzig gültige
verstanden wird wie es ja vor der
aufklärung üblich gewesen ist und auch
in kirchlichen bereichen da noch lange
darüber hinaus weiter gedauert hat dann
liegt das eben sehr nahe dass man die
grenzen befestigt aber es ist nicht nur
dort selbst also mit relativer wahrheit
brauchen sie wahrscheinlich in einem
bestimmten moment wenn sie eine
bestimmte weltanschauung einen
bestimmten politischen haltung
verpflichtet sind brauchen sie die
möglichkeit grenzen zu setzen
greenpeace wird in seinem vorstand
wahrscheinlich auch nicht jeden ferrari
fahrer haben wollen
dessen auto 25 liter benzin verbraucht
ja hoffentlich nicht weil sie sonst ein
glaubwürdigkeit weil es da in lahr
würdigkeit problem gibt aber greenpeace
vertreter ja nicht die meinung es gebe
eine absolute unumstößliche wahrheit und
keine pluralismus die ketzerei ist ein
einzelgängertum gewesen gab es auch mal
sowas wie gruppen ketzerei ja also
entstanden ist das ja vom von der
wortbedeutung verleitet sich ja von
katar her
die katarer in südfrankreich diese
aufbruch bewegung die also kollektiv
sich gegen die gesellschaftlichen
überlieferung gegen die normen gestellt
hat und dann entsprechend bekämpft wurde
als gruppe sie haben der ketzerei den
namen gegeben die kata wir einen ein
ketzer den ich noch gerne ansprechen
möchte das ist ja nur der böhme er war
ja wirklich auch so etwas wie ein
vorposten also er hat eigentlich sein
leben für etwas eingesetzt was den
nachfahren dann zugute kam
er hat es nicht eingesetzt man hat
natürlich nicht als held nach konstanz
gegangen
soll man hat ihm freies geleit
zugesichert und war dann diese hat dann
dieses versprechen gebrochen als er hat
nicht selber sicher dass das leben
eingesetzt aber es stimmt natürlich
dadurch dass dann später die
reformatorischen traditionen viele der
anliegen von johannes wieder
aufgegriffen haben ist er dann auch zum
vorläufer geworden das ist jetzt von
bedeutung nicht erinnern uns jetzt an
hus im zusammenhang mit dem konzern von
kommunal nächstes jahr ist 600 jahre her
dass er zum feuertod verurteilt wurde
dann erinnern wir uns an ihn also er war
wenn man so will ein sehr moderner kerze
eigentlich für das fünfzehnter
jahrhundert ja so gesehen also ketzer
thum und das haben sie angesprochen hat
natürlich insofern immer etwas mit
modernisierung zu tun als eben davon ein
anstoß für veränderung ausgehen kann und
muss kann auch dafür stehen
hier ist allerdings noch die komplexität
gegeben dass er eben auch für eine
nationale idee steht oder vereinnahmt
wird je nach position wird das
unterschiedlich gesehen also das was uns
damals machte das was bruno giordano
damals machte das ende endete dann noch
auf dem scheiterhaufen endete mit dem
tod
später gab es dann das schweigegebot man
durfte nicht mehr veröffentlichen oder
wie sie vorher erwähnt haben die bücher
wurden verbrannt
also scheinen doch die ketscher irgendwo
im laufe der jahrhunderte eher wenig
einfluss auf die kirche genommen zu
haben weil es sie doch immer wieder neu
gebraucht hat ich denke nicht dass der
einfluss so gering zu schätzen ist also
wenn sie einen lieblings keller von mir
nehmen
alfred bozi der französische ex eg im
zusammenhang mit dem modernismus streit
also mit der frage wie zb die bibel zu
lesen sei der azubi die katholische
kirche zu beginn des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts in den grundfesten
erschüttert hat und bei denen also dann
quasi der stw
nicht man eine publikation zum schweigen
verbot auferlegt hat ist es doch
immerhin so dass er dann heute sogar in
jesus buch benötigte 16 zitiert wird
also man kann durchaus hier einen
einfluss konstatieren der fast
unangreifbar erscheint von daher dürfte
man es nicht zu geringe chancen also
eine langzeitwirkung aber eine wirklich
sehr lange zeit hat es gebraucht bis es
gewirkt hat das ist sowas braucht
furchtbar lange es sind viele
hingerichtet worden auch immer wie
thomas müntzer ist am ende hingerichtet
worden
kann man sagen ketzer sind letztlich
auch so was wie marktführer gewesen
in gewissem sinne schon aber eben es
hängt weniger von der qualität ihres
zeugnisses abgesagt als vom kontext vom
umfeld von der situation der
gesellschaft ist die stabil oder ist sie
verunsichert ist sie ruhig oder ist sie
unruhig sind die autoritäten gefestigt
oder brauchen sie irgendwelche
hilfsmittel oder oder vorwände um sich
selber an der macht zu halten
es ist mindestens so stark eine
herrschaftsfreie wie es eine märkte ihre
frage ist wenn sie es noch mal für sich
zusammenfassen welche rolle haben die
ketscher in den letzten jahrhunderten
der kirchengeschichte gespielt waren sie
waren sie letztlich waren sie stein des
anstoßes haben sie uns wirklich
vorangebracht
ja die auseinandersetzung mit neuen
ideen und abweichenden meinungen ist
natürlich ein motor des des diskurses
gewesen gewollt oder ungewollt
dabei darf man aber natürlich nicht
vergessen dass das tragische geschichten
ist wenn ein einzelner mensch unter
herrschaft und repression unter macht in
dieser weise leidet dann muss man zuerst
ja nicht an die kirche oder diese auf
das ganze denken sondern einmal das
schicksal dieses einen menschen und die
verantwortung die man ihm gegenüber hat
auch im nachhinein
sicher ins auge fasst und die
historische kirchen also ganze kirchen
geschichtsschreibung käme ohne die
ketzer gar nicht aus sie haben es auch
voran getrieben wie kommenden ketzerei
ihren studenten an
ja also das ist ein element in der
kirche historischen entwicklung
allerdings das studium von vom von
catcher schicksalen ist eigentlich nicht
biografisch motiviert also eine
studierende person heute würde sich
nicht so sehr für bruno interessieren
wegen seines individuellen schicksals
wie sich jetzt das abgespielt habe
sondern vor allem als indikator für die
frage wie haben die menschen gelebt wie
haben die menschen ihren glauben
praktiziert was lässt sich daraus
schließen über die entwicklung gläubiger
existenz insgesamt vielen dank für diese
einsichten und das gespräch markus rieß
dann kann ich noch hinweisen darauf dass
der berühmteste ketzer über den wir
jetzt noch ein paar mal gesprochen haben
ja galileo galilei war sein geburtstag
jährt sich zum 450 mal in diesem jahr
und über ihnen bringen wir jetzt gleich
im anschluss einen film
die akte galilei hasst er von fritz
kalteis